quand on autorise des regroupements dans
des grandes surfaces commerciales et
qu'on impose aux stations de fermer elle
qui offre des grands espaces et bien on
peut se poser la question de l'équité de
traitement
[Musique]
il nous
qu un peu c'est le fait que nous sommes
ici dans des grands espaces et qu'on
aurait été en capacité à d accueillir
cette clientèle qui de toute façon été
très très remplis en baisse considérable
par rapport aux saisons normal tout le
monde porte des gants les skieurs sont
habillés de de la tête aux pieds
donc en termes de protection
individuelle je crois qu'on on est au
maximum
les décisions parisienne si vous voulez
elle arrive en mode pyramidal si elle
était un peu plus concertée avec avec
ces territoires elle serait encore une
fois mieux comprise on pourrait mieux
les expliquer nous sur le terrain quand
on autorise des regroupements dans des
grandes surfaces commerciales et qu'on
impose aux stations de fermer elle qui
offre des grands espaces et bien on peut
se poser la question de l'équité de
traitement
les blessés du ski qui seront évidemment
moins nombreux puisque la clientèle le
sera le sera moins et ses blessés de ski
qu'il faut rappeler qu'ils sont traités
directement par les cabinets médicaux de
stations où 95% d'entre eux sont traités
par les médecins de montagne et les cinq
autres pour cent qui finissent à
l'hôpital reste une heure une demi
journée mais n'occupe pas non plus des
lits de réanimation ça peut arriver mais
celle infime partie des cas
[Musique]
cent quinze nuits n'aime pas le fils
si vous y allez
les pluies
[Musique]
amour
les commerçants sont vendée but et une
saison compliquée ça va être morose ça
va être moins lumineux que d'habitude
alors que toutes les conditions sont
réunies pour vivre la montagne comme
elle se vit c'est à dire avec des chutes
de neige en suffisance
et puis une ambiance je dirais paysagère
qui est simplement exceptionnel
évidemment les professionnels de la
montagne ne sont pas indifférents la
situation sanitaire du pays on la
comprend et on était en mesure de
proposer des solutions
maintenant encore une fois noël nouvel
an c'est déjà du passé pour nous on
souhaite travailler sur l'avenir et
reprendre notre activité tout de suite
début janvier c'est une période qu'on ne
souhaite pas conserver dans nos mémoires